في اوروبا السباق على تامين الغاز من اجل
فصول الشتاء المستقبليه يشتد ومساعي ابرام
صفقات الغاز الطبيعي المسال مع الشركات
الامريكيه متواصله فما التزايد المخاوف
بشان امن الطاقه يسعى الكثير من
الاوروبيين للحصول على الغاز لمده خمس الى
عشر سنوات وفقه صحيفه وسط رجل التي اشارت
لوجود مخاوف كبيره لدى بعض مسؤولي الشركه
والحكومات الاوروبيه الذين يترددون في
توقيع عقود توريد طويله الاجر والاكتفاء
بوضع اهداف طموحه من اجل استهلاك الوقود
الاحفوري بشكل كبير وفقه مراقبين فمخزون
الغاز في الاتحاد الاوروبي ممتلئ بنسبه
95% وهو ما سيجنب القاره كارثه طاقه كانت
وشيكا مع اقتراف فصل الشتاء لكن من
المتوقع ان يصبح شراء الغاز لفصول الشتاء
القادمه اكثر صعوبه بالنسبه للدول
الاوروبيه بعد ان تخلت معظمها عن
الامدادات الروسيه والتزايد المنافسه
العالميه على الغاز الطبيعي الموسى
فالكثير من الشركات الالمانيه تحديدا التي
تعتبر وتعتبر محرك التصنيع الاوروبي بادت
قلقه بشان امتلاك طاقه كافيه للجزء الاخير
من هذا العقد حيث قامت باجراء محادثات مع
مصدرين غاز الطبيعي لموسال الامريكيين حول
صفقات امدادات الغاز المحتمله التي يمكن
ان تبدا بعد منتصف العقد كما اقترح
مسؤولون الاتحاد الاوروبي تشكيله مجموعه
من الشركات الاوروبيه لتنسيق محادثات صفقه
الغاز والشراء المشترك للوقود في المرحله
المقبله واشارت الحكومه البريطانيه الا
انها تعمل مع الموردين المحليين والدولين
لاستكشاف العقود التي يمكن ان تزيد من امن
امدادات الطاقه غير ان المشاكل الرئيسيه
مشاهدينا التي يمكن ان تعرقل مسار نجاح
هذه الصفقات هي سياسه التسعير والاهداف
المناخيه اذا يقول بعض المراقبين انها قد
تعرقل الاهداف المناخيه الهادفه الى خفض
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري
[موسيقى]